there's so many things I want this
Christmas
none of them are things that are spring
peace on earth goodwill to men terminal
illness defeating vaccine I want
solutions to bigger global problems like
violent police and fascist rulings but
those aren't things that can come by
Christmas so I guess this Christmas I'll
take things oh that's great Alex so what
kind of things are you looking for this
Christmas huh you're Jewish right I want
for children to not be hungry
and for people to not be sad
I love the world - stop fighting then
the world would be so bad
[Music]
ever
these but it's year for Christmas
I'll take things
[Music]
expensive things that new things that
remind me of older things tangible
things intangible things necklaces and
jewels and other shiny things of course
I'd love to stop the oil drilling no
freaking fracking and don't [ __ ]
spinning but this year Christmas
I'll take things what else oh well
there's a few things I want for everyone
to be with their families never have to
fight in wars I'd love to see the end of
racism man
[Applause]
water policy those can't come before
Christmas Eve so shucks I guess this
Christmas I'll take
[Music]
fancy things are the things digital
money for physical things normal things
stranger things physical body for
digital things things halt halt halt
things
oh no no no
Christmas morning Christmas this year
Christmas this year for Christmas
Hanukkah Kwanzaa ramadan in buddhism
thursday two
[Music]
[Music]